one
good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday hope
everybody had an amazing weekend today
is such a special day I am still down
here in Florida and I needed a co-host
and honestly there's nobody better
nobody greater our older sister Olivia
is here joining me hey Liv hi thank you
so much for having me you know what's so
funny is like people don't know me yes
well we have so many new toasters yeah
and you haven't been on the toast in
quite a minute the last time you were on
the toast I don't even think you were a
mom of two yet were you so the last time
I was on the toast was audio when you
were at Stagecoach yeah so I don't like
know how much that counts even though I
know you have a significant amount of
podcast listeners so it definitely
counts but the last time I was video you
were still both of you were still in the
New York Studio I was still living in
New York yep I remember that that was
great we have that one photo of you and
me which will be like we'll take another
one today and it'll be the only photo
used for the next like two years yeah
that's the thing with Olivia's birthday
I can never find a photo that either I
don't hate or she doesn't hate yeah so
we we have that one photo from the last
time and today's we'll take a photo
after this and hopefully we both love it
yes however we did decide yesterday in
the car that we're over that like toxic
we did we had that conversation I used
to be absolutely crazy about it like I
was one of the first people like when
Facebook came out that like I had to
approve my tag photos and I just want to
say like I'm done with that like if I
look bad in a photo
you can go [__] yourselves for talking
about me behind my back you know we used
to be so crazy like when we would take
family photos all four of us we would
have to like pass the phone around to
edit it we were so mean and you know
what like I think that's part of growing
up like just [__] it like it's so
exhausting to care so much she cares so
much and I just like I don't care
anymore no I like to do okay I do but
not at the scale that I did yeah I care
but like really not as much as I used
I'm sorry I just feel like I talk so
loud you know by the way so this is a
problem we have at the toast I talk so
[__] loud yeah and Jackie um talks at
like a normal person because she's like
a quiet little girl she's lovely
um so my audio is always louder than
Jackie's but you're loud too so today
we're just gonna bust the speakers bust
the windows out your car you know
um are you a Glee fan I am but you know
I I watched Glee like when it was on and
then I stopped like when I went to
college because it was like you were too
old yeah I never stopped
you know what's so funny like you I feel
like we talk about this every time you
come on the toast because we end up
talking about Bravo and you really
invented Bravo in the family of course I
remember when we were really young you
were watching like Jill's Aaron and
that's how I started getting into it but
now I know you don't watch it anymore
but like what are you obsessed with pop
culture-wise like I I'm a Gleek you know
I'm a Swifty I love Twilight like I have
my things what are your things I know
you're like a mom of two now so you
obviously have you know like priorities
Beyond Twilight
um I'm Alex are all obsessed you are
yeah I just love like I live for her
tell me why because you want like even
though she's like the most like gorgeous
creature with the sickest body like I
really just resonate with that like
going out getting drunk like like just
like that Vibe like I was that person
and when you're in it you feel like
you're never not gonna be it but now I'm
so not it that it just like it gives me
like beautiful Nostalgia for it you know
that's a really good way of appointing
it that's like when they say you know
you don't know that those are the days
until the days are over yeah yeah yeah
so I'm really like obsessed with her and
like I'm just not like into things that
people are obsessed with like I do not
watch Vanderpump Rules I am like
personally boycotting the new rahoning
for so many reasons I just cannot get
behind this stuff but there will be
select things that you'll be like Olivia
I think you'd really like this like the
first season of Salt Lake Real
Housewives I really enjoyed that and I
think it's because like I just really
love the state of Utah like we've always
had wonderful times being there
um and I just liked that newness Vibe
um but yeah no I'm I'm in I'm sorry you
said like you trust my opinion if I say
like Olivia okay I will watch you until
then okay guys Olivia will not [__]
watch you put it on and I was watching
it like I was enjoying it but it's just
like here's the thing it's like I'm not
like sitcom girly like I don't watch
Friends I don't watch the office like
what I'm looking for is not something
with like 12 Seasons That's like
syndicated and on for forever I'm
looking for like murder mystery gonna
find out in the last episode after eight
was part of this limited series that
like the who done it done it no I get it
I get it but will you trust me that like
I'm your sister I love you I know you
and I know what's good for you and young
shelters by the way I'm not resisting
it's just not the priority for it
probably like today or this week but
that doesn't necessarily mean like like
next month starts August so like it
could be the priority for the month you
know okay I just I just know you and
Zach will love it and it's family
friendly Kayla can watch it too yeah no
no listen like I'm not not down you know
yeah so for anyone who's new here Olivia
is our older sister she's the you know
she's in charge of us she always has
been in charge of us
um except some of us just can't be
managed but she tries um you're a mom of
two I am Michaela and Levi like the
absolute apples of my eye and I really
wanted give everyone an update because
whenever I come down here I pretty much
sit on the podcast and like talk about
how Michaela will not acknowledge me I
like give her so much love I'm obsessed
with her and I just want her to
reciprocate that and she's like the
sweetest little girl to everyone except
for me now you guys are the same person
yes we are like we have a lot of like
toxic chaotic energy totally so I wanted
to give everyone an update because I've
been here now for like five days and
it's a it's a different girl Michaela is
you agree like obsessed with me she's
obsessed with you yeah and she kind of
like always was but like you guys like
to toy with each other you know like no
is like because she loves the attention
romanticoya I know but it was not she
was not like playing with me she just
really didn't like me and I don't know
what it was maybe she's just grown up a
little bit maybe I'm a little bit more
calm I mean I'm not but we have had such
a fabulous like I don't know when I'm
leaving but when I do like I will never
leave that I will cry I will cry I know
Michaela and I were so connected and we
never were and it's just I mean like you
fully got in her bed I got in her bed
and she didn't like cry she let me lay
in the bed with her yeah she lets me
take pictures of her we have like little
photo shoots on my camera when she
dresses up like it's just it's been such
a delight and I just honestly wanted to
bring you on here to say thank you for
giving birth to literally the queeniest
queen whoever queened thank you so much
yeah she's pretty epic she's such like I
think everybody got a little glimpse of
her in your Tick Tock when you're like I
want to address something and she's like
I want a dress too she's so girly she
loves dress she loves Belle she
literally hysterically cried this
morning because I would not put her back
in her Bell costume I'm like it's Monday
morning like you cannot wear a bell
costume she also cried last night when I
got her ready for bed she wanted to
sleep in her Bell costume yeah I think
maybe we have to get her more costumes
because she's only wearing the belt by
the way she does have other costumes
like she has an Elsa and then she has
like this other one that's kind of like
garden fairy Vibes and like when she's
into something like she's into it like
there's just no other way we're so
similar like when she becomes obsessed
with something I know thanks to me I got
her obsessed with High School Musical
you did but like that kind of ship has
sailed right now no when I got here she
got in bed with me I'm like what do you
want to watch she said High School
Musical well because I think that's like
your thing now but she's like actually
my kids are super like Levi especially
he's the cutest little muffin man in the
world obsessed with like 1950s musicals
so like we're really having like a Bye
Bye Birdie moment right now Singing in
the Rain like we listen to Bye Bye
Birdie in the car Kayla's like we love
you come on like my bedroom wall a share
a wall with Kayla's bedroom and we put
her to bed and I'm like well I'm laying
in bed with Ben like turning down for
the night and this is what I hear we
love you can ride oh yes we do
so Olivia's going to join me for the
Fast Five today we've got real actually
very good stories
um I threw a little business news in
there because Olivia is our record
resident marketing girl like Olivia
knows everything about like you know
business so she's going to give us some
advice uh actually she's gonna give Elon
Musk some advice so I think without
further ad do that do that do it is time
for the past five stories that you need
to know today's episode of the toast is
brought to you by Caraway Caraway
cookware is non-toxic and it's chemical
free so you can fill your summer with
your favorite recipes without any worry
calorie makes cookware with the
convenience of non-stick without the
concerns of toxic forever chemicals so
you get the best of both worlds you know
I'm staying at Jackie's house where she
has literally every Caraway product ever
Ben and I have been living it up you
know making chilies doing our worst and
cleanup is so easy I mean Ben hasn't
been a part of cleanup I have and I can
say it's been pretty easy and caraway's
summer refresh event is happening June
20th to July 15th for a limited time get
10 off the internet's favorite
kitchenware it's a perfect time to take
care of all your summer gifting it's
ideal for both graduates and newlyweds
with cookware bakeware food storage and
tea kettles to choose from there's
something for everyone caraway's
internet famous kitchenware is a staple
for any home and it comes in variety of
modern Shades to fit with any design
aesthetic they're non-stick chemical
free ceramic coating makes the easy
cooking and clean up the non-toxic
kitchenware means that foods can be
prepared with peace of mind that no hard
to pronounce chemical will leach into
your healthy ingredients all of their
sets come equipped with complementary
easy access storage solutions so if you
live in a tiny New York apartment with
no cabinets like I do it's super easy to
store all your Caraway products they
make it so easy they've truly thought of
everything
carawayhome.com toast10 to get 10 off
during their summer refresh event
certain exclusions apply that's
carawayhome.com toast10
t-o-a-s-t-10 or just you'd use code
toast10
t-o-a-s-t-10 at checkout Caraway
non-toxic cookware made Modern
today's episode is also brought to you
by the farmer's dog whether you have a
few weeks old puppy or a senior dog
who's seen multiple decades any dog
person like me knows that the most
valuable thing in the world is spending
time with your pet the farmer's dog can
help keep them healthy which can give
you more quality years with them so what
is the farmer's dog I'm so glad you
asked it is a company that makes and
delivers fresh healthy dog food it is
recommended by vets it's nutritionally
balanced and it's made from human grade
ingredients in safe clean kitchens it's
truly the best option for dogs at any
stage of life because it's not kibble
it's not canned it's not processed it's
real food so traditional dog and wet
food options that I'm sure a lot of us
know they're really processed they use
lower quality ingredients and they are
extremely difficult to portion
accurately but when you sign up for the
farmer's dog you take this quiz they ask
so many questions about your little
Stripes bro so you really feel like they
get to know your dog and we'll put
together the proper package for you so
if you're looking to maintain your dog's
weight this is a great way to do it it's
one of the biggest indicators of living
a full healthy life for your dog Theo
switched I mean so many benefits like
his poops just are better you know
they're more concise they're smaller
um his fur is so shiny his breath oh my
God his breath was so bad not to be rude
but it was truly horrible
um and a healthy diet isn't just
important for humans we love our dogs so
much like let's take the best possible
care of them so it doesn't matter if
your dog is young or old it's always the
right time to begin investing in their
health it'll help them live healthy
happy years together with you so get 50
off your first box at the farmersdog.com
toast that's 50 half five zero fifty
percent off your first box at the
farmersdog.com toast okay our first
story is something that kind of consumed
my weekend I saw the news and then I
kept seeing like different tick tocks of
different angles of this incident and I
keep learning more information about it
but I really want to talk about it cardi
B throws a microphone at a concert goer
who tossed a drink at her while
performing in Las Vegas so I feel like
we all saw the clip but if you didn't
during an outdoor set at a beach club in
Vegas the Grammy winner became the
latest musician to be targeted with
items thrown at them during a
performance so in a now viral video of
the incident cardi can be seen wearing
an orange dress during the performance
and looking surprised when a drink is
thrown in her Direction while performing
bodak yellow in response cardi threw her
microphone at the front row attendee
whose security seemingly escorted away
after the incident the rapper tweeted a
different video of the angle
which shows a clearer view of the fan
attempting to throw their cup
um at cardi B who reportedly continued
to her performance after the mic toss so
um so many thoughts so many thoughts
okay my initial thought I was like you
know what good
[__] around and find out [__] like we
live in this age where people are so
entitled when it comes to celebrities
Bebe rexha Kelsea ballerini like we see
it all the time and I feel like as a
performer you're you know you're taught
of course to never respond the customer
is always right [__] like that and
you know what no
[__] I'm gonna throw something at you
now of course first Cardi's you know
weapon was a lot heavier and more
painful I think than a cup of liquid but
you know what like the other girl
started it so at first I was like you
know what cardi B well there's a lot of
things to unpack here because I watched
like 45 000 different videos of this
last night and I learned a couple of
things and I think it's important to
share yeah number one apparently at some
point during this earlier on earlier was
it earlier yes okay she said like spray
me basically like you know like she told
people to like uh
she said to Splash her [__] like yes
yeah I think it was enough by the way
there's a big difference between hair
and face and fuzzy I just want to say
yes of course yeah but when I saw that
I'm like oh come on like then you're
opening the door for people to throw
stuff at you yeah and I feel like when
you're a performer in this day and age
like that's just a big No-No like I
would never you know I think all
performers would agree like never
encourage that because okay someone
throws a cup next thing they throw their
shoe like yes you're opening the door so
once I saw that I was like a little less
on cardio the side I'm like oh yikes
because yeah the girl was doing pretty
much exactly what cardi asked her to do
yeah I think you know it's a classic
case of it's uh Teresa Giudice like flip
switch okay like yeah I just think
actually like something happened and she
reacted like and that's almost why like
I feel right in the middle of this like
I feel like I can really identify with
both sides but I feel like it's
something it reminds me of that time
when you me and Ben I think we were in
AC and like you splashed the milk at me
and like you thought it was so funny but
it's like my god do you know Olivia how
you react like you just react because
like something happened and like your
brain can't process it fast enough
Olivia you just unpacked like the
craziest memory I have to tell this I
can't wait till you Gaslight the [__]
out of me and tell this story
I think I would tell it accurately we
were in Atlantic City I think we were in
the hotel room right in the hotel room
and you know they had like that coffee
machine with those little creamers that
are in those little tiny um like cup
things yeah and I was thinking like if I
just squeeze the bottom of this cup like
all the creamer will explode and I was
like I'm gonna do it and you were like
don't do it and I was like I'm gonna do
it and you said don't do it and I did it
I got creamer in your hair and you well
the creamer was expired and it smelled
like donkey okay and I literally she
flipped I flipped but by the way and
it's like you just react because
something happened you know by the way I
totally understand like the most yeah
that wasn't what I did talk about the
real part of the story that's the
hilarious part
like she was lip syncing because the
music kept going so there was like a
whole that's what a lot of people aren't
talking about is like the second she
threw the microphone she obviously
couldn't sing anymore and the track kept
going although I do think that's
actually a very common thing for rappers
to do is to sing or to wrap over their
tracks because there's like background I
don't know I saw some people talking
about that too honestly I don't really
care I don't care either I'm just trying
to I like I watched so many different
videos of this that I was just trying
because like you know when she threw the
microphone she didn't actually Hit The
Girl Who Threw I knew the cop like she
did somebody else so then that's another
level of like party kind of being in the
wrong because she hit the wrong girl and
then this innocent girl gets a big ass
microphone thrown at her yeah and
somebody said she has a single coming
out so she's just looking for a headline
like I saw that's really a lot a lot
Tick Tock is where you get the news and
the girl who threw the cup like the
second she released it saw cardigan mad
and said I'm sorry I'm sorry I know like
it wasn't malicious cardi like I'm sorry
cardi did open the door so like I was
ready to come on here and be like love
this yeah because I think like what I
would love to do to the guy who threw
his phone at Bebe rexha like right choke
right so but finally someone else
getting it in return but like I don't
think this girl was the one to get who
deserved it I know I agree with that and
I think also yeah
I know it said The more we learn the
more we learn like and you have to keep
learning everything you have to keep
[__] learning you have to keep
learning it's like you came to take the
video at face value like even when
you're ready you're like I'm sure we all
saw the video now but like the video
would that video even stand up in court
no no you know what because it's
circumstantial
right sure it's circumstantial yeah
um so yeah I think you know I'm not on
team card even though like and I'm not
not on team cardi do you know what I
mean yeah cause like I totally I want to
see a video of when she said Splash my
[__] I think I just wanted to say [__]
on the dose all the time I think we need
to go back and see that then and like
did people Splash like what happened
people did Splash when she when she
asked them to Okay and like that part of
the show was over and the girl didn't
get the memo but right but but cardi
opened the door like I know I know I'm
saying like sound off in the comments
are you team cardi or team girl
let us know
um okay next story I know you're
obsessed with this story I probably
would have chosen it anyway but I
specifically chose it for you thank you
Lisa Hoxie she is slamming her estranged
husband Lenny for getting engaged to his
mistress while still married so Lisa
hoxine sarcastically congratulated her
estranged husband Lenny hoxtein and his
mistress Katarina mazepa on their
engagement so Lenny revealed that he
popped the question to his girlfriend of
one year he is 57 she is 27.
um despite being legally married to Lisa
still and Lisa then took to Instagram
shared his post and wrote congrats to my
current husband and his mistress on
their engagement then she also slammed
Lenny's mom so Lenny's mom had left a
comment on his engagement post and wrote
I will be very happy that this time you
are getting a woman who loves and
respects you you certainly did not have
that in your previous marriage good luck
congratulations that's what Lisa's
mother-in-law Lenny's mom had commented
and Lisa shared her comment and wrote
what a wonderful mother-in-law and
grandmother how disgusting
yeah and that's that's the thing about
this that I do not like which is like
there are kids involved and yeah you
know like it's like they have two young
kids the dad the parents are still
married they're having a very
contentious divorce the dad obviously he
had an affair yeah and this is the woman
he had in a fairway right and then you
just like run off into the sunset before
like you have you know settled and it's
just one thousand percent wrong it's and
it's like what's the rush what's the
well he is 57 and she's 27 so maybe
there's that two like they can still
have a baby and like not get do you know
what I mean like it's just so
disrespectful it really to get engaged
while you're still married and you have
kids and then Grandma [__] off Grandma
what are you doing Grandma's a [__]
because that lives on forever and the
kids grow up it's now a new story they
see it their last name is hoxtine they
Google themselves it's like what the
[__] are you doing no it's so true
grandma was being a wench yeah and you
know they were just like looking for
headlines and I just hate people like
that no like oh by the way I actually
under understand people who are looking
for headlines I hope to be one of those
people myself one day yeah but for doing
something else at the expense of your
own family like that's where I draw the
line like that's so like evil and that's
just the crazy thing about divorce is
that like yeah you really see sides of
people that you didn't even know could
possibly exist not only that but like
you will find yourself doing like the
lowest of the low things to somebody who
you would have at one point taken a
bullet for yeah you know I think the
thing that is really interesting about
this and one of the things that is
interesting about reality TV although I
don't always partake I do love love is
blind that is the one I know you do I
just felt like anything you're such a
artiste girl
how dare you how dare you I'm actually
like not a fan of anybody that's ever
been on the show I think they're all
actually what about the Hamiltons
I feel like you love them I just can't
believe that they're still together but
they're weird to me you know you want to
know why like love wins like they loved
each other yeah they did they did except
he also like loved another girl or two
no he didn't like she was crazy yeah I
don't know if we as a like country will
ever be as unified as we were during
season one of Love Is Mine no 100 I
can't remember and those are the one the
relationships that I think are the
strongest yeah of course I also just
can't remember a time where like
everyone was talking about this one
thing more than we were during season
one of Love is Blind maybe White Lotus
but that's it yeah but there were even
people who like didn't watch The White
Lotus like yeah I don't know a single
person who didn't watch until I was
blind totally Shapiro is obsessed
obsessed to be unbelievable because it's
like a circus it's a freak show it's a
freak Show and it's the best and the
people that are going on now just want
to get famous and my favorite thing
about it is like they don't get that
famous like that Chicago crew is the
worst all those girls went on because
they wanted to be famous and now they
all like have fake podcasts together and
like nobody cares about them and it's if
you go on the show like the first one
was such a true experiment and nobody
really knew what was happening and now
the rest of these people just try to
play the game yeah we knew that it was
going to turn into like this Global
phenomenon that the people who were like
the stars of season one would end up
becoming like actually famous yeah and
there's a lot of talk about Lauren and
Cameron maybe
um taking names
Vanessa's job I'd be here for that me
too they're they're like true
celebrities yeah and now that people
know that that's a possibility the
amount the the group of people you're
gonna get applying for the show is just
different different totally yeah but you
were making a point about Lisa and Lenny
you said the point that I was making was
and we we learned this with the Richard
sisters is like
anything that is going to be uncovered
is uncovered when you're on reality TV
you can't hide anything and like Lisa
and Lenny I did not watch but from what
I read in the Daily Mail like their
divorced played out on the show and
everybody I think unanimously took
Lisa's side right like course people saw
what was happening so I understand he
was caught on a hot mic during the
season like right before they announced
their divorce and he was just like
talking [__] he was like I'm getting the
[__] out of here like I'm seeing someone
he brought his mistress into the house
while Lisa was wearing a microphone like
actually the footage they got on Miami
Housewives was crazy crazy so like so
that and then he takes it a step further
to get engaged while they're still
married and it's like the mom his mom is
then gonna go and do you know what I
mean we've now seen that Lisa is a
stand-up Galley right she puts the kids
first she did the right thing in her
marriage no skeletons have come out
about Lisa and what she did behind the
scenes and then y'all are gonna keep
doing this you know what I mean like
it's like if she did something negative
in the relationship if she was cheating
on him if she was nasty to him if she
didn't put the kids like always feel
like he has something to be mad like he
would have a reason it would have come
out and he would like he's doing all of
this why yes he does want to be married
to Lisa anymore okay you can still act
with dignity like yeah you're right and
then give her a proper divorce and move
on nothing has been uncovered about them
you're so about her yeah so it's like
why are you doing all this just because
you're mean like it's giving mean girl
yeah it's giving mean girl and Grandma
really it's giving me grandma because
Grandma should know her privileges like
I don't know how do you keep your kids
around someone toxic like that yeah no
grandma should know better too like
you're supposed to be older and wiser
and she was I mean I watched the first
season of Miami because you know I'm OG
Bravo when they did the live reunion the
best and if you've never seen it you
should just go watch it because Adriana
demura is but Olivia she's still on now
and she's so [__] insufferable what's
crazy I could see the OG Seasons she was
my favorite yeah she she's horrible yeah
well people change people change um
Lenny hoxtine right so net net team Lisa
all the way and honestly I just in
situations like this I just feel so
terrible for the kids of course and
that's how I'm feeling no and divorce is
bad I think you know no matter what
especially because the kids are young
and divorced is bad and they live in my
I don't you know like Miami is such a
tight-knit community I feel like the
kids going to school like it's just all
drama and why do young kids need that no
I mean divorce is terrible for kids I
think at any age but when there's the
element of like things being on the
internet living like existing forever
it's just really sad and you need to
when you're in the spotlight like you
need to do better for your kids and you
need to act right and Letty and his mom
are acting wrong they're acting 100
right and Grandma's a wench all right
our next story is kind of about our
co-host which is really crazy Harry
Styles flashes a new tattoo
and it says Olivia and I just want to
know like when are you gonna tell
Shapiro about your man like really
uncool of you Harry Styles has been
spotted with a tattoo believed to be a
dedication to his ex-girlfriend Olivia
Wilde in photos obtained by Page Six the
former 1D singer can be seen flashing
the tattoo on a boat in Italy on Friday
so he shows off what appears to be the
word Olivia Inked and italic on his
thigh the word collazione which is
Italian for breakfast also appeared to
be Inked on his leg it's unclear if
there's any connection between the
tattoos but it literally says Olivia and
then like underneath it it says
but there's like six inches
um there's like six inches of space I
don't believe that they are related
related well so I have a couple
questions on this like have we ever seen
this part of his thigh before to like
know that this is super nail that's a
good question he is wearing the tiniest
bathing suit anyone's ever seen like
yeah it's like I could see his penis
bones and then I could see like his
pubes it's a really tiny baby it's very
European very
um so I don't know I I'm sure that
historically like in the summer he's
been on vacation he's always getting
Paparazzi done Yachts we would have
noticed if this was there before it's
definitely not because they have that
song One Day something about Olivia so
it's like maybe that's the John Mayer
song no there's a little bit different
song yeah yeah but one thing about
Olivia is John Mayer okay I live for you
I long for you Olivia okay so maybe
there's an Olivia's life that we don't
know about it's a testament okay and
it's me they didn't write their own
songs back in the day like those Wendy
songs actually don't have any meaning to
any of the guys like they were in part
of a machine you know it was horrible do
you ever see their documentary
I don't think so but honestly I would
enjoy watching that it's one of the best
don't get me started on my celebrity
documentary Tyrant everybody's heard
enough but like that's a really good one
it's a really good one I actually I I
love a documentary so what's your
favorite celebrity documentary
um
I don't know actually I feel like you
like to Amy I loved Amy yeah and I love
her I I feel like I can't it's too much
pressure right now to like think right
off okay that's not a thing you have but
I heard the jelly roll one is really
good did you see it no it's on Hulu I
actually would watch that yeah his story
is very interesting very interesting and
I like his wife yeah she's a podcaster
is she they've been together for like
before he was famous yeah no I know he
was like in jail and I believe he was
homeless and yeah a kid and they met and
she like got him an apartment and was
like listen yeah I don't know if we're
gonna be together forever watching
tonight yeah but okay 100 Shelly we'll
let you know tomorrow jelly roll on the
toast yeah um so
Harry Styles has a tattoo the girl who
clearly represents a tattoo is no longer
in his life do you remove the tattoo do
you remove the tattoo
no I think a lot I mean I don't have any
tattoos so tattoo Community don't come
for me but I feel like people get
tattoos and even if it's no longer
representative of them at that moment in
time it was at one point and tattoos are
almost like it's like memorializing
elements of your life that yeah it
doesn't have to be like does Pete
Davidson still have Kim as my lawyer no
oh well that's and he doesn't have Kim
it doesn't make my point but and he
doesn't remember he got kid the kid's
letters he got like and I think if
you're like gonna get a tattoo and
you're not like committed to going all
the way despite the fact that like it
might not be your future forever you
should probably not gonna no but that's
the thing with tattoo culture now it's
like when you have a bunch of tattoos
like you can get them changed he he
changed the game is my lawyer one you
can cover it you can change it you can
add different letters that's like la la
Ken Ted Rand
forever Randall Emmett and then he ended
up being like the horriblest human and
she changed it to brand new
love that for her yeah so it was like
there are ways so now I feel like
tattoos as also with tattoo removal like
it's not as like crazy to do like I
believe you know remember when Ariana
got like Pete Davidson's dad's FDNY like
shield on her foot no but okay I believe
it's long gone it's either been covered
what's up with like the people the T
Pete Davidson tattoo Community is its
own little orb it's so true
but I agree that I think some people use
their bodies as like storyboards for
their life and so you don't have to get
a room 100 maybe they ended amicably and
he could acknowledge it that was like an
important relationship in his life and I
think that's very mature of him and it
seems like something that would like
that seems like his Personality yeah
he's like so like yeah emotive yeah like
he's not like bitter Lenny hochsteiness
now we don't have any tattoos because
we're two Jewish Queens but if you were
to get a tattoo do you ever think about
like what you would get
like no but I guess we could like think
about it here you know I've thought
about it yeah
and I would get the word because I feel
like yeah you would say I get my kids
but like you could have more kids than
you have to update the tattoo right so
it need to be something all-encompassing
like and what's so important to us
family I would get mishbacha cute maybe
on my forehead I was just gonna say
where would you put maybe connecting my
eyebrows to give me one long eyebrow
and i would support that and what would
you get have you thought about like what
you would get for a tattoo no but like I
think placement is so interesting you
know you get it above your ass crack
obviously obviously
um and then like
I don't know I feel like people do like
sorry I don't I don't want to show my
feet but you want to get it on your feet
no you know like people do like a little
like ankle or toe or like here there's
no things doing like tiny micro tattoos
on your fingers that's like all like
Haley Bieber has I have a friend that
instead of wearing like a wedding ring
he has like a ring tattooed and I think
that that's very lovely yeah his name is
shingy he like people know him and you
can never take it off yeah and so you
have to be married for life I think Ben
should do that yeah I I really think
it's actually very sweet that is a sweet
one yeah um so I highly recommend going
to look at these photos of Harry Styles
not because of the tattoo because
honestly who cares but it's such a teeny
tiny bathing suit like look at that I
mean he was not interested in having tan
lines and I respect that and I just
think everybody should go take a look at
that because it's definitely important
you know for society today's episode is
brought to you by vague more you know we
are always trying to do right by our
bodies when it comes to hair and scalp
we really were um adamant about finding
a product that actually works but it's
also made with clean ingredients and
Jackie was the one who started using
vegamore first and got me into it
because you know I hate talking about
this but like a few months ago I really
started to experience hair shedding and
I was looking to have my hair look
fuller and thicker and just healthier
um so the vagamore grow kit is
everything I'm obsessed with the serum
the shampoo and conditioner so it's
giving us the ability to have thicker
fuller shinier longer hair without all
those harsh ingredients all the vagabort
products are 100 cruelty free and they
are never formulated with potentially
harmful chemicals like parabens or
hormones so what's even greater about
the grow kit is that because it comes in
like the essentials kit where you get to
try more than one amazing product but
also at a great savings so when you sign
up for the monthly subscription you save
more and you never run low on the
products that you need to take care of
your hair I'm now on like month two of
the grow like really being rigorous and
being consistent with it the
subscription is so great because I don't
have to worry about running out and I'm
starting to see results and I feel so
much better like I had a lot of not like
bald spots but just thinning around my
scalp in the front when I put my hair up
in a ponytail you could see it and it
was like really embarrassing so the hair
serum daily
um is what I've been using and the
shampoo and conditioner it just keeps my
scalp healthy and flourishing so give
yourself the hair you never thought you
could have with vegamore for a limited
time the toast listeners get 20 off
their first order by going to
vegamore.com toast and using Code toast
to check out that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 off your first order
vegamore.com toast code toast
our next story is a little bit more
celebrity drama Teresa Giudice is
calling Sophia Vergara the rudest
celebrity she's ever met so she said
that Sophia regards the weirdest
celebrity she ever met during a latest
uh podcast episode of hers she was
chatting with her co-host and she
recalled an incident from 2017 where
Vergara allegedly appeared reluctant to
take a picture with the reality star
backstage at a talk show and Teresa
argued that Vergara should be nice
because she's uh I just felt like I
needed to be Jackie in them Teresa
argued that Sofia Vergara should be nice
because she's quote an immigrant what
yeah so so if you ever go this is what
she said quote Sophia Vergara's PR
person and my prsn spoke together and I
guess the two of them said let's get a
picture of Teresa and Sophia together I
didn't want to take a picture with her
I've never asked to take a picture with
anybody she's the rudest woman I've ever
met she goes on
I saw her whole demeanor and then I
heard her say to her PR person why are
you making me take a picture with that
lady I was like excuse me I did not want
to take a picture with you I never asked
to take a picture with you she further
claimed I was like how rude you're so
not humble you're not a humble person
you forgot where you came from it's not
like she started out like being on the
top she forgot where she came from she's
so not a down-to-earth person
that's what she said
um and I just have a question about I
have so many questions about this yeah
like of course everyone should be nice
and let's say for argument's sake Sophia
regard was not nice you know immigrants
can be whatever they want like I don't
know why [__] to bring immigration into
this 100 and like isn't she an immigrant
too from Italy her and her husband
ex-husband no I think she was born here
actually that's a good no because he got
deported
can you not
can you only get deported if you're not
from here
I I would I guess you can't get deported
why not where would you be deported to
no you're right you can't you can only
get deported if you're not from here yes
or her husband or ex-husband the father
of her children and then she's talking
about her and by the way I think the
amount of people who have you know
negative interactions with Teresa
Giudice like oh so this is what I was
gonna say I have like a decent amount of
experience with like Talent right and I
think in situations like that like where
the pr people are just like pushing you
around to take photos this and that like
you don't actually know what's going on
no and so you know it's so fine to be
like why are you making me take a
picture with that lady I'm sure Sophia
Vergara has no [__] idea no idea and
maybe she wanted the context right like
so that's not a crazy thing to ask no
and I think also this is a classic case
of like perception not being reality
right so like did Teresa hear her say
that or did she like see her mouth move
and then like assume that she said that
like this is like a non-situation that
she's making seem like Sophia Vergara
wasn't nice to her and like maybe she
was cold but like it's not like I don't
know she splashed water on her at a
concert like it's not the same it's
literally the um
it's ego I didn't want a picture with
you but you wanted a picture with me
it's like like why are these two even in
the same room like where were they in
the same room they were both appearing
on a talk show and so they were both
backstage in different green rooms and
the pr people like communicated with one
another was like oh my client we should
get a picture PR people need to stop I
mean it's just the fault of the pr
people because honestly like why does
the world need a picture of Teresa
Giudice and Sophia Vergara we don't we
don't we absolutely do not and there's
like you know with a lot of people
there's like a six degrees of separation
there's not yeah you cannot bring these
two together in any way shape or form
there's no connection none none what's
the weirdest celebrity you've ever met
hmm that's a really interesting question
there's this one podcaster actually ooh
I'm kidding I was gonna say you oh I'm
like wait what podcasters are you I've
had really Pleasant experiences with
Talent actually I am a person that likes
to focus on the positive okay you're
really not but okay I like to focus on
the positive they're actually one of the
most negative people I've ever met
including myself like I'm negative too
how am I negative you just are like if I
came back and like if you went somewhere
I'm like oh how was your day like the
first thing you would say would be the
bad thing like that's not true that's
not true all this weekend I said this is
the most glorious day
I am admittedly like a very negative
person yeah I don't think that's a bad
thing I don't think I'm that negative
but honestly like if you think I am I
will do the reality I will digest the
feedback accept it and move on I think
you were definitely like an extremely
like negative person I think extremely
is I I could be negative I don't think
I'm extremely okay here's my barometer
is me like I am a negative person and I
pale in comparison to you I think that
that's absolutely false I think you
should ask some of our sisters I
absolutely will and I think that they
would say that you're more negative than
I am no 100 okay I'm putting it in the
scenes chat yeah and hopefully they'll
answer while we are live these are lies
I came on here what would you say is a
more negative person question mark me or
Olivia question mark oh none of that
went through
who would you say is a more negative
person question mark me or Olivia I'm
still trying to think about my most
negative celebrity encounter
okay I really
I think you should just totally honest
no I sent it
all right I'll let you know if they
respond because you're most um negative
celebrity encounter my one I always say
but like I've really moved on from
Hillary I heard she's awesome Ben said
she's so great I know yeah and I think
maybe like my experience with her was
like true maybe you were the Teresa
Giudice and she was the Sophia Vergara I
mean I was literally 16 and all I wanted
was a photo with her and she told me
like stop following her around yeah I
was never the type of person that I'm
like if I saw a celebrity I'm like I
need a photo with you or I need your
autograph you know who's the first
celebrity you ever met in person
oh my God I don't even know oh I know
who was we tell the story all the time
Veronica's the Veronica is yeah but they
were like weren't even celebrities they
were yeah I think they were shocked at
like anybody cared about that like two
people came out and there was four of us
yeah
I don't know I really don't know that's
such a great question I know so many of
my memories are like so deeply buried
you know it would really like take I
don't know like trauma repression it's
trauma repression I don't remember
anything nothing when I was an intern
though
um one of my jobs was like basically
being like a butler for talent like I
would just come in and be like you want
drinks whatever yeah and they were like
really famous people
um there like you were you worked there
too who do we meet then we met everyone
like from reality stars to A-list actors
yeah
I don't even know but like every day it
was like somebody hella famous yeah
Salma Hayek yeah yeah yeah yeah no I'm
fighting even before that I worked um I
feel like people don't even know this
when I was at NYU I interned for Nanette
Lepore for one semester do you know what
that is wait they answered me what'd
they say I'm in shock yeah it's you I
mean they both said me thank you
Margaret said you and Jackie said oh
that's tough you what thank you you're
delusional you need a reality I'm a
shock I'm in shock yeah you're the one
that actually needs to get up oh my God
you are so negative I'll stand by that
okay and by the way nobody's saying that
I'm not negative you're just um very
much more and I said that the word
extremely was the wrong word to use I
just negative I feel like I'm I'm such a
ray of light like what are you guys
talking about like I think that your
negativity is a ray of light because
it's comedy it's funny yeah no but like
I'm always thinking about how much I
wish I was someone else just so I could
hang out with me like I'm a ray of light
I'm a delighted because you're obsessed
with yourself doesn't mean that you're
not that's not what I'm not I'm not
saying I'm obsessed with myself I say
like I always make every situation fun
I'm always that doesn't mean that you're
not negative though no it does like I'm
a literal ray of light because people
who are like uber positive can be like
super [__] annoying to be around
toxic positivity is a real thing yeah
you and your like verbs for things like
trauma repression
It's actually an amazing point you need
like a dictionary of like these words
I'm like a woke internet user like I
have a word for everything okay trauma
repression is real I know are you trying
to silence the victims of trauma
repression
I can't even respond to that I am a
victim of trauma repression I can't
believe everybody said I'm negative like
I'm honestly I'm feeling so Vindicated I
wish my phone was in my hand too so I
could just say big thank you to Claudia
to Jackie and Margo I'm in shock they
both said me why are you in Chuck
because you're so negative I know but
like I'm second to you you don't give
you you can't even see your own Shadow
girlfriend no but like okay maybe that's
something I need to work on because
right and I said I would accept and to
adjust the feedback from you and now you
should accept and digest the feedback
from your sisters I can't like I'm I
refuse to accept it I'm not believing
what is that called being denial
negative dancing videos no it's like
denialism or superioristically
[Music]
story you know like a denial supremacist
no it's a hunchback who can't see his
own hunch totally totally all right
what's the story even about oh it's
Teresa Giudice oh yeah so I'm just
saying I'm team Sophia obviously and why
you got to bring immigration into it
yeah and you know I'm just I I said it
at the top of the show because it really
like there is something called like the
Teresa judice flip switch and nobody
flip switched is more than hers it's
true like if you watch Housewives like
you know that Teresa's perception of
reality is so worked warped she like so
I have a feeling this entire interaction
went a totally different way but this is
how she received it so while I'm here
and just to like get educated what is
going on with Teresa and Melissa and
like how are they both gonna be on the
same show well so that's the thing it
got really bad at the end of last season
like fighting about everything Teresa's
new man he went into business with Joe
then it got bad and then Joe hired him
Louis the boy and the new man hired a
private investigator Bo Dino like it was
really really bad
um and they were like Teresa was like I
will never film with you again blah blah
so everyone was like all right Melissa's
obviously gonna get fired and now
they're I think they're about to start
picking up and I believe they're all
back so I don't know
you can't go on reality TV and like keep
anything under the covers like it just
doesn't stay there yeah because these
people need to make a living and they
make a living by exposing theirs and
other people's secret so team Lisa
all right our fit and final story is a
little Tech Biz news you know last week
Elon Musk was tweeting and explaining
that Twitter is going to be rebranded
it's going to be called X
um the logo is going to change the name
is going to change and honestly like
people were freaking but I'm like this
is just Elon being Elon like I didn't
think like for a second that this was
actually going to happen but on my phone
now I have X yeah
uh it really went through and he is
explaining himself to CNBC he said
Twitter was acquired by x-corp both to
ensure freedom of speech and as an
accelerant for X the everything app so
this is not simply a company renaming
itself but it's doing the same thing the
Twitter name made sense when it was just
140 character messages going back and
forth like birds tweeting but now you
can post almost anything including
several hours of video in the months to
come we will add a comprehensive
communication and the ability to conduct
your entire Financial world the Twitter
name does not make sense in that context
so we must have bid a due to the bird so
let me just say like his explanation
actually makes sense like the platform
isn't tweet anymore like you're not
saying dumb little thoughts it's much
more concise you can write essays I
totally get it you can live stream
whatever having said that like I just
think this is bad marketing like to get
your your the name of your product to be
so integrated into culture like tweet
like everyone it's just so
yeah
but what's the word I'm looking for
ubiquitous ubiquitous thank you so I
just feel like to give that up is so
dumb yeah what do you have a couple
thoughts because I agree like when I
first heard it I'm like and there were a
couple things that like from me from
like more of like a marketing
Communications background I just think
the rollout was so shitty you know where
it's like okay if you saw like I saw a
bunch of tweets about this where the
main Twitter logo changed to X but all
their other official Twitter accounts
like Twitter Sports oh still the bird so
it's like they should have like really
pulled it up Twitter sports right yeah
like they had they didn't change
everything all at once like and if
you're saying that you're going to build
this super app which like that's what I
want to get into it's like and the
financial of it all wouldn't have made
sense well then like launch a new
feature or a new product where like
Twitter in that context wouldn't have
made sense and then do the Rebrand there
I'm like I don't necessarily agree with
the meta Rebrand of it all but like they
really went deep into web 3 when they
did The Meta announcement so like it was
combined together other I think the one
thing that everybody's trying to solve
for which I think Facebook originally
tried to do and they weren't doing
successfully is like pretty much like in
China like there's one app and everybody
uses like one app for everything right
oh a Super App instead of having like a
million apps like we have here and I
think what Elon is trying to do is he's
trying to recreate that here and I feel
like other people have tried to do it
and tried to and it's and Amazon I think
to some extent has some elements of it
because like they have Whole Foods
they're launching Healthcare you can buy
anything in the world shopping they have
home shopping you can be a seller on
there and run a business right like
but there's an element of social media
that's missing from Amazon which is the
core part of the super app in China
isn't that what Instagram's been trying
to do though since day one because every
time like they had a good idea it became
popular for posting photos and then
Snapchat stories were things so they
became Snapchat stories then Tick Tock
became a thing so then they just started
doing reels they like stole everyone's
idea in the hopes that like just in the
context of social media I'm saying just
social media yeah I would say Instagram
is definitely like a super media so like
a social media super app so yeah yeah
it's like a tongue twister I didn't know
super happy but they didn't like combine
everything else together like Facebook
owns so many different things plus with
their web3 Investments Oculus WhatsApp
like if they brought WhatsApp and
Instagram all in one like that starts to
create the vibe of a super app so I
think that's what Elon is trying to do I
just don't know if here in the US like
we're gonna operate that way yeah we're
just like not those sort of people like
people are very brand loyal they feel
like very definitively about the things
that they care about they use isap they
use this streaming service like think
about how many streamers we have like
fifteen thousand you know it's not like
one super streamer app and Americans are
also like very passionate like yes like
they know who owns certain apps and they
don't want to support Zuckerberg or they
don't want to support Elon so like
they'll stop themselves from using apps
just because of their own like
principles yeah yeah 100 so I think like
I feel like that's not a thing it's a
long-term move that it was done
short-sightedly because it needed a full
comms plan and it needed a rollout that
included elements of a super app because
by the way on X so I was playing around
yeah and it's like your your thought now
called an
axis it's kind of like on X now I'm
typing something the button to publish
is still called tweet
you're right Half Baked
I'm all down for a Rebrand and it needs
to be very well thought out I don't like
the name like oh check X or have you
seen what's on X today I know it's it's
hard to Fathom but then like once it
happens it happens and you like can't
imagine life without it you know now
that we're like a month or two I forget
even when they created like go puff they
were like go puff it like somebody in a
room was probably like that sounds
really [__] weird but now that's what
people say that's actually a good point
and now that we're like a month out um
what are your thoughts on threads
because I was really excited about it
like week up and then probably three
days in I completely forgot about it I
haven't checked it since same same I
think that's I read somewhere that
everyone was freaking like 100 million
people signed up the day I read that
after week one they had a 70 drop yeah
yeah because like been there done that
like it exists in another way so if it's
like I understand like trying to bring
all those things together but that's not
how people use Instagram today so it's
such a big like consumer Behavior shift
and so like people get on it because
like they want to see what it's all
about but it's not natural it's not
normal for us so like we're not really
gonna partake in it
exact same way my tweets were or my
tweets my threads were all about like
being a hater of their own yeah no and
then everyone was like so excited about
it and I genuinely cannot remember the
last time I checked it yeah but and I
was so excited too because I loved that
it would just import from Instagram so I
didn't have to build a whole new
following I already had like 200 000
followers I just I think if they had
built the functionality into Instagram
so in the feed you were seeing people's
thoughts like again nobody wants another
app that's kind of what they tried to do
remember when they had like status
updates yeah but like the way that was
bad yeah and by the way that lasted for
actually all of two minutes by the way
it still exists do you have people who
put I don't want to call them out but
there's two people who I like them both
so they're always [__] doing it I'm
like who are you talking to it's time
for you to unfollow those people no but
I like them but I'm literally like who
are you talking to yeah yeah nobody's
looking here you know they're needed to
it needed to be integrated in a better
way yeah and also like the fact that
they was like not threads.com like you
have all the money in the world
Instagram like go relieve that business
up there what do you mean threads.com it
was an app no I know but like when you
went to so like online like they did you
access threads on a website I don't know
if you could access it on a website or
if it was just like the download the app
button here yeah like they didn't own
threads.com that's a big mistake big
mistake if you can't some random company
that had to put a thing on their site
that said we are not Instagram really
yeah go look oh my God I didn't see any
of this hold on that's so funny if you
were threading about threads you would
be in the threads threading about
threads okay wait it's threads.com
a slack replacement
you see the button oh my God yes okay so
it's it's a it's a it's a service for
businesses it's basically like um slack
or Gchat and it literally has a button
on their website we are not associated
with Instagram that is so funny this
business could have like literally
probably made like 20 million dollars by
selling their.com right right and they
should have just done it yeah
they could have just changed like
chatthreads.com or whatever yeah
interesting yeah no you know the thing
is is like we in the US I think like
behave differently than other you know
countries yeah in other countries and
um yeah I don't know I'm a fan of
rebrands even as like unnecessary as
they may be sometimes yeah but it has to
be well thought out this just like kind
of felt like a rush like and that's the
thing about Elon a little bit which I
like appreciate also like he has an idea
and it's like okay you know it's a
little erratic but I think like having
been part of a couple of rebrands like
the ever you have to really turn over
every stone and if you're not doing that
it's just not going to be a successful
Rebrand like people need to understand
like the way that he has to go on CNBC
and explain themselves like you should
have just you showed a letter of like
here do you know what I mean like there
should have been like a brand
positioning that went out with it no
that's actually really true so what as a
professional marketer yourself what were
your thoughts on the toast Rebrand
absolutely loved it any notes like
things we did incorrectly no like again
you did it you there was an announcement
behind it all the assets changed at the
same time it was well thought out it was
because you were ever evolving with your
community in the way that they referred
you like right you didn't just go and
call it
the foreign
that's like too much
actually fun fact for anyone who's new
here is Jackie and I first started doing
a podcast it was called the morning
breath and Olivia was our showrunner
producer literally Booker everything yep
those every day those were the days do
you miss working with us ever I do I do
but you guys are like so successful
awesome and killing it on your own like
it's so great to just kind of be a fly
on the wall that's so nice I think that
sometimes we miss you I miss you guys
you're just like very organized like
you're a great businesswoman and you're
really smart and we're definitely
missing that thank you yeah no but in
the beginning when we like you guys have
such a well-run operation now people
don't realize like in the beginning I
mean what it started at was me and my
janky hands holding two phones one was
Facebook live one was Instagram live and
I was like we couldn't we didn't even
buy a tripod it was like the first
episode ever of Jackson Claude we were
literally using Olivia's arms as tripods
and honestly I don't know how they
didn't break me either me either and
like honestly for everybody that was
there because I people always comment
and they're like I've been here since
day one it's like have you been here
since that day yes yeah which is like
I'm I'm sorry like you probably got a
seizure you know I would absolutely love
to go find episode one of them you just
like found a room and like did and
there's so many learnings that have
happened along the way like look at this
setup now like you know how to like HDMI
into the US right right and then export
to ABCDEFG you know like I don't know
how to do that stuff but I think like
you really kind of you guys did this all
on your own like it's amazing not really
because you were there I was there I was
there in the beginning it was it was
great times thank you for joining the
toast and thanks for coming over already
yeah we killed those Fast Five I think
that's sad well we don't have to be done
what else do you want to talk about
girlfriend no I don't necessarily have
anything else to talk about it's just
been so lovely being here with you I
just love having you here I know it's so
crazy how I'm really like a patreon
girly yeah the patreon community knows
me really well thank you so much for
bringing that you're welcome I meant to
promote this at the beginning of the
episode but we put a vlog up on our
patreon yesterday that people are
calling
Academy Award winning they're calling it
literally Nobel Peace Prize worthy
um we went to Costco I'm not a Costco
girl but Olivia's husband like literally
wants to be buried at Costco and he goes
you know a couple times a month and we
joined him on the trip oh my God it was
fun at first I was like into it I was
impressed and then it slowly like
devolved into like the most insanely
torturous exhausting day I'm not trying
to be negative
the Vlog is available at patreon.com
people are obsessed with it I hope you
guys enjoy it I'm gonna try and make
just a little bit more content while I'm
down here
um and if anybody was wondering where I
was I was taking a two-hour nap and it
was glorious and somebody had to watch
the kids like yeah and I came home and
there was like a beautiful Diet Coke for
me in the fridge like it was just
absolutely gorgeous yeah that is the
kind of the one fatal flaw of the Vlog
though is that you're not in it I know
but I'm spoken about a lot like it's
really interesting that you guys think
like I would like blueberry muffins okay
do you like blueberry muffins like
they're okay but that crumb cake one
definitely looks much better what a
mistake when I rewatch the Vlog I'm like
why did we not get the crumb cake yeah
there was something else that you guys
said that I liked it was just like
making me laugh why oh the wine stuff
yeah yeah but you actually didn't buy
any wine yesterday because we don't need
refills no yet so it's a great Vlog uh
Olivia's husband Zach has featured in it
quite a bit I've been heard I've been
heard I've been told that he's a star
yeah he is a star he's so funny he's so
serious he's so literally I couldn't
even get him to talk on the Vlog because
he was so focused at Costco like it's
kind of like a military operation for
him yeah everything is like kind of
threw off his Vibe like the way that you
went in and you're like okay let's go to
get the meat first and like he doesn't
do that like he starts at the produce
yeah like he has his whole we were being
toxic for sure he has this whole like
path forward
um
and it was definitely an experience for
him I think like he kind of loved like
being on camera like he pretended like
he didn't but he loved it that's the
thing with vlogging like it's addicting
it's addicting you know when he was like
filling up the gas and being interviewed
like he really thought that he was a
star also if you want to hear more from
Olivia you have to go to her Instagram
at Olivia ashtray o s h r y she posts
fabulous mom content cooking content
you're really an amazing cook what are
you making us for dinner tonight I don't
know what do the kids want I don't think
I would like hate like a chicken stir
fry okay I like to make things that
people ask for you know I don't think I
would mind like an Asian fusion like a
rice and a stir fry kind of moment maybe
a fried rice done done and done I feel
like the last time you were here I made
something like that too because like
that's what you like that's what I like
I like what I like yeah so make sure to
follow Olivia on Instagram I could use a
few more followers yeah you could never
have enough it's like how does my sister
have three million and I don't even have
a hundred thousand you know you're fine
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast thank you I love you thanks
for listening to the toaster Monday
Morning Show where we did the fast five
stories you need to know everybody the
Friday on YouTube so you're watching
it's on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available on Spotify